foreign
[Music]
so much
and maybe
maybe if you open yourself up to it
there's a possibility I don't think so
Quinn
quell
I don't think so well what I'm trying to
say Peter you know this is an open line
right what we're listening to everything
you're saying and it is painful and
you're just telling me now we were
hoping I would stop on its own but I
switch it over to private what color
button did you push blue for the blue
suit oh no blue was the Open Line for
everyone orange is for blue what black
is for orange yellow is for green green
is for red and red is for yellow no
yellow is for yellow green is for red
red is for green I don't think so try it
though
hello
you're right
[Music]
let me tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
meta girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
she came back a total dick oh please he
left out some important information but
that is the gist of it
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
perfect
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight beside my friends
incinerate them
thank you
we're always searching for a family
until we found each other
are you ready for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
a beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
ever noticed how black your eyes were
they were replaced by my father as a
method of torture he he picked a pretty
set
thank you
[Music]